you know it seems like we weren't  designed for the environment that we  live in that last last week i had  hermann ponceron who who lived with the  hugs us and they're not struggling with  addiction they're living in their  natural environment  yes i mean one of the main points i make  in dopamine nation is that we are living  in a time of unprecedented access  to highly reinforcing  drugs and behaviors  and that the smartphone is essentially  the equivalent of the hypodermic needle  delivering digital dopamine 24 7.  and our primitive brains have really not  evolved for this environment so it's  really the mismatch between our our  brains and the world that we've created  which has led to a lot of suffering if  you look at the top reasons for  death and disease across the globe  it's related to our sedentary lifestyle  our diet and and to addiction